you must you take eight it's normal to
expect that we're always going to almost
by nature actively seek out our own
happiness especially in two big areas of
potential satisfaction relationships and
careers so it's order new not a little
unnerving to discover just how often
some of us appear to act as if we were
deliberately not to ruin our chances of
getting what we are on the surface
convinced that we're really after when
going on dates with candidates we like
the sound of we may suddenly lapse into
unnecessarily opinionated or
antagonistic behavior hello hi Ellen
what are you doing Friday night
Yeah right
bill bill Jenkins no bill didn't do very
well
and we have no difficulty being charming
with the types we weren't so keen on
well in relationships we may drive our
partners to distraction through repeated
unwarranted accusations or angry
explosions as if we were somehow willing
to bring on the sad day when exhausted
and frustrated our loved ones would be
forced to walk away still sympathetic
but unable to take so much draw and
similarly he could destroy our chances
of promotion at work when out of the
blue after lots of promising years we
get strident with our managers on
several occasions failed to hand in
really important reports in time for
meetings such behavior can't be
explained away as may have bad
it deserves a stronger more intentional
time
this is self-sabotage what could
possibly explain such destructiveness in
large part how plain unnerving happiness
can sometimes feel to us though
happiness is of course what we all
fundamentally want for many of us it
isn't really what we know we've grew up
in and learnt to make our peace with far
darker scenarios the prospect of
happiness when it in the end appears can
therefore seem a bit counterintuitive
and not a little bit frightening it
isn't what we've come to expect and it
doesn't feel like home we may prefer to
choose what's comfortingly familiar even
if it's difficult over what is
alienating ly fulfilling or good getting
what we want can feel unbearably risky
it puts us at the mercy of fate we open
ourselves up to hope and subsequent
possibility of loss self-sabotage may
leave us sad but at least safely
blessedly in control it can be useful to
keep the concept of self-sabotage in
mind when interpreting our and others
order behavior we should start to get
suspicious when we catch ourselves
pulling off erratic performances around
people we deep down really like or need
to impress furthermore faced with
certain kinds of viciousness and
unreliability and others we should dare
to imagine that things are perhaps not
quite as they seem we might have on our
hands not a nasty malevolent opponent
but an almost touching ly wounded self
saboteur who chiefly deserves a little
patience and should gently be coaxed out
of doing themselves further harm we
should come to terms with and help
others to see just how hard and
unnerving it can sometimes be to get
close to some of the things we truly
what
you
you